lo que voy a hacer en este vídeo es
escribir las expresiones algebraicas que
representan lo que se establece en los
siguientes enunciados el primer
enunciado es la suma de menos 7 y la
cantidad ocho veces x tenemos la suma
así es que va a parecer un signo de más
aquí de menos 7 menos 7 al cual le vamos
a sumar la cantidad ocho veces x la
cantidad ocho veces x que también
podemos escribir como 8 x menos 7 + 8 x
esto representa la suma de menos 7 y la
cantidad ocho veces x hagamos el
siguiente toma la cantidad menos 3 veces
x menos 3 veces x y luego sumarle uno y
luego sumarle uno la cantidad menos tres
veces x la podemos escribir como menos
3x y luego le sumamos 1 es decir más
hagamos ahora menos seis menos seis más
menos seis más vamos a escribirlo aquí
menos seis más el producto de menos uno
y x el producto de menos uno y x que le
puedo escribir como menos uno por x 1 x
que es igual a menos x esto lo podemos
escribir como menos 6 más menos x lo
cual es exactamente igual esto es
equivalente a menos seis menos seis
menos x y así hemos concluido